Hi everyone, in this lesson we're going to look at some primary nodes and textures when
it comes to working with materials in Unreal.
So let's get started.
So some of the primary nodes we're going to be looking at is the base color, metallic,
specular, and roughness.
Later on we'll talk about emissive and we'll talk about some of the others like ambient
occlusion.
But for the most part we're going to focus on these four initially.
And you'll see in our little sample image here that we have some little numbers here.
These are our constants.
These constants are punched into each one of these particular variable options inside
of our material.
Now the thing about these is these can be constants where they're just a singular number, they're
just resting in here, something you set and just keep on going on with your material workflow,
or they can be turned into a exposed as a scalar parameter or create a scalar parameter
out to get go and plug it in.
Now I'll show you how to do that because there's a quick way to do it where you just promote
a parameter for each one of these.
But this is the initial ones we'll be looking at within our material editor and then we're
also going to be looking at some textures here in just a second.
So let me point this out real quick in Unreal and we'll go back into the texture concepts.
So in Unreal we're just going to click on this material, one pic on this guy, and I'm
going to double click on it and bring him up.
This is a thing called a material instance.
This is just a child of the parent.
We'll talk about that concept in just a bit.
But I want to go ahead and go into the parent material here.
I'm going to double click on it.
And you can see now we have these base materials active.
You'll see we have a base, we have a metallic, we have a specular and we have a rough.
But you'll also see that there's a number of variables so you can punch in those ahead
of time if you wanted to.
And you wouldn't even have to actually connect anything.
Now what I meant by promoting, you can simply right click and say promote to parameter.
This turns it into a scalar parameter.
And when you do, this scalar parameter has a definite default, a slide minimum, and a
slider maximum, as well as you can categorize it into a particular group.
And you'll see there's groups already have set up here.
But I just wanted to point that out what that's all about.
I'm going to disconnect this by simply clicking on the connection node and keeping my finger
on the Alt key and that actually automatically disconnects.
We're going to do a full walkthrough of the interface here in just a bit, but I wanted
to show some things quickly in context.
Let's go ahead and talk about texturing and we'll get back to these concepts later.
So our base color, Elbido, is a flat color without specular or shading.
We have a linear RGB vector three values of zero to one.
And we want to avoid pure black and pure white because they just don't show up in nature.
Now then again, if you have a stylized piece you're working on, you may lean in that area
because you just need to push those values.
But for the most part, for realism, you're not going to you're kind of kind of shy away
from that.
We're there.
We're trying really hard with science seems to be getting closer to pure black and pure
white.
But for the most part, you're not going to see that.
Metallic here is a grayscale value that ranges from zero to one.
Most common usage is an honor off state.
So one or zero.
When I want one, it deals 100% specular reflection and zero is going to be zero going to be none
and anything in between is going to be a variant of them.
And you can see the full scale spectrum here.
You can see it has hardly any and then we can see that it's fully metallic.
Actually not, I should say.
And in the middle, it's kind of in between.
And then we have roughness grayscale value that ranges from zero to one also, but it
ranges from smooth mirror like surface zero to a rougher matte surface, which is one.
Unlike both metallic, you're encouraged to fine tune the roughness value between zero
and one or use a texture to that effect.
So using no texture keeps the material slightly lighter.
Again, this depends on resolution.
This depends how many times you're using input values versus an actual texture.
This really just depends on what your overall scene is going to be.
They can add up after a while if you decide to just use numbers.
But for the most part, you're going to use roughness as a texture.
Let me give you an example.
If I had a really old piece of leather, I would have a high roughness value in there
to demonstrate how the variance change between the light and the old dollar parts of that
leather.
And the same thing with rusty metal versus shiny metal, you can use roughness values
for that.
Using a range, obviously it's not a specific, but using a texture is going to be very specific
to sell the concept.
So specular grayscale value that ranges from zero to one.
So good rule of thumb is to set the specular value to 0.5 and fine tune it.
Now a lot of times what I'll do is I'll turn my specular all the way to zero.
I'll turn it off and let my roughness push the values.
The only time I'd fire up my specular, if I need to push a particular look, which we're
going to do later, such as super shiny, over the top wetness, that's where you can actually
bring in specular.
But you've got to be careful because roughness and specular can influence each other and
they can turn each other off or mute each other if you're not careful.
So what I like to do just for a good rule of thumb, I turn specular to zero and I focus
mostly on my rough.
So guidelines.
When you're building your texture, you want to try to use a power of two.
The reason why you want to is that makes it so the Mipmaps are working accordingly.
And the Mipmaps are kind of your LOD, you can think of it that way, level of detail for
your texture.
And you can do 16 by 16 or you can even go as high as 8,000, 8K if you wanted to.
And the textures don't have to be squares, you can have something like a 2048 by 1024
or a 2048 by 4096, you can definitely do that.
And that's really up to you.
But you got to keep that thing, you got to keep that in mind that power of two is what
you want to hit, because then you can control that Mipmap if you need to edit it, like smooth
it out, make it blurry.
And for some reason you have a repeating pattern and it isn't quite reading right and you're
getting more patterns happening.
So texture pyramid, let's look at speaking of Mipmaps.
Let's talk about that for a second.
So let's jump into Unreal.
I'm going to go ahead and take a look at this Megascans material.
Just click on the magnifying glass for the folder if you're wondering how we got here.
And I'm going to double click on the salt mine here, wall, I'm going to double click
on the texture for it.
And I'll just pick on the albedo so you can get an idea of what we can do.
Now obviously I can roll mouse in and out with my wheel mouse here.
You'll notice we have RGB channels that we can take a look at.
This is super helpful if you're inheriting a texture you may not be familiar.
And you know that they've painted in the channels you can see where the channels are
at and what they do.
This again just shows us all the different channels for that particular piece of texture.
And over here you'll see that we have our Mipmap Gen settings.
And you'll see it says texture group.
Now the time that you would mess with these or edit these if you're getting some display
issues that aren't quite working out.
Case in point say you have a chain link fence or you have a roof that is a repeating pattern
you might want to blur it or sharpen it.
If you're getting a more a pattern or a very weird distortion happening, you can actually
use these settings here to be able to change that if you need to.
Now you'll notice there's an LOD bias.
We're not going to really mess with this one, but as the bias is to the index of the top
MIP level to use, that is the number of MIP levels to drop when cooking.
So overall you have a zero by default and you kind of want to keep it there, but you
do have the option to change that if you need to.
And for some reason you need to customize it for a particular device such as a phone
or iPad and those change whether they're high level iPads or lower level.
You have the options to be able to customize all of this to be able to do so.
You'll notice there's a texture group though.
This is a world because this is a texture that's isn't particular to a set of UVs.
This is something you put on the wall so it's considered world.
And you can change this.
You can say, hey, this goes to weapon.
This goes to vehicle.
And the reason why you do this is helps with compiling your shader.
And ultimately when you send things out the door to be packaged, you're actually telling
Unreal what to look at first.
So it doesn't have to pick walk through everything else.
So you're kind of just isolating.
So we got an advanced area here too.
This allows you to control some of your downscaling if you needed to.
And again, all of these are mainly to control whether you're going to, you know, maybe you
need to adjust the compression.
You know, maybe you need to never stream this.
Maybe it doesn't need to stream.
All these things are in here so that when you build out your texture and you need to
edit things by default, all this should work just great.
But there are times when you will need to change things such as compression.
Now later on in another class that we have, I'll demonstrate and point out that there's
an option to be able to change these if you need to say, hey, I need something to be really
high end HDR, maybe have a series of images I want to project on a wall or on a geometry,
you can actually choose that.
And also you can say I want to clean it up a little bit so there's less blurring on some
of my alpha areas.
So you can choose any of these to be able to help out what you want to do for your particular
texture.
And these really do come in handy after a while.
You notice there's more advanced here.
We can control some of our maximum texture size for this.
You're like, hey, I don't want this texture to go any higher than this.
You can control kind of a compression setting if you need to.
And that actually makes it so that you're resolutionally hits a particular amount.
So there's a lot of options.
Now I'm not going to go into about knowledge here because not all of these will necessarily
be necessary, but they are available for you to explore more if you need to customize your
texture and make sure everything is performant.
For the most part, if you're keeping in mind what your hero objects are and your objects
in the background and you're keeping those resolutions maintained and using virtual texturing,
you may not even have to dive into these very much at all.
But they are available because we want you to feel drunk with power.
We want you to be able to customize things the way that you need for your project.
So these are available here.
You'll notice there's also a brightness and brightness curve, vibrance and saturation.
We have these set here.
I recommend if you are going to mess with these.
Now you do get an arrow that says, hey, send me back to default, but I would recommend
you make a copy of your texture and then try to play with these.
That way you can do a comparable between whether you like the new version or the old version.
And that can be pretty helpful.
And at the end, you'll see here there's file path compositing and a few other advanced
things, but we're not going to get into those just yet, but they are available here for
you again for full customization.
Now we can use the import button in our scene if we want to, but we can also go in here
and you can simply drag in a texture that you need.
Let me demonstrate and unreal really quick because there's several ways to bring in what
you want.
Say in my scene, I need to bring in a emergency sign.
I need to bring it in and I need to use it for my scene.
Now I can do an import here.
You'll see here I can look for it on fab if I need to also.
There's a hot key for fab or hot button, I should say, or I can simply just open up the
folder where that icon is at and just simply drag it into my scene.
So.
And it import is done.
You can see, hey, look, now I have a sign in here.
Now I do need to change the unreal is nice and will order any kind of weird name.
I just got this from the internet, but you do want to try to name this so that it's a
little bit more catering to unreal's naming scheme.
And I mean that by putting underscores where you can.
And we can just put this as a T for texture in the very front.
Cool.
So there's a couple ways that you can import things and those are two of them and makes
your life a bit simpler.
That's it with this lecture.
Here's a link below to dive deeper into this particular topic.
In the next video, we're going to take a look at material editor overall and we're going
to look at parent materials and how to work with those workflows.
Thanks again.